so so what would happen if you just said  I don't care about the money like I will  I will work with you like you can do  your side piece thing yeah I'm cool with  that too no I think but it's more him  believing in him accepting that it's not  that wasn't all I want was it because in  like the relationship before was it like  did you is that something you got on him  for no never okay but it's he's con he's  concept of women is women will stay with  you if you have money because a lot of  men now especially like the Andrew Tate  lovers believe that if you don't have  enough money a woman would leave you 100  yeah so this is the problem is me I will  stick by his side with God